this film would like to blend uh
my tai chi or
i mean tai chi and qikong maybe classes
different things but if you don't have
chicken you can't actually perform good
quality tai chi chuan form
so
i'd like to blend it with meditation
because to me
they sort of overlap
i hope they do so it's just
exercises that i give you i don't give
you the form in the touchy
side so first of all
find a space somewhere that you're
comfortable with
and you know just check
just check the pieces you know
shoulders arms
legs
hips
i always suggest that if you're not
really michael chilled out
to do some stretching do some exercises
do everything
i like to uh
in the morning start off we've done this
on another film i start off
like this back and forwards
lifting my heels coming on my toes so
there's a point where i'm on both toes
there's a point
when i'm on both toes
after you've done what you consider
something to loosen up your body you may
find our your back's still tight well
you could spend
an hour or two
working on it and if you've got that
much time then please do it
today i
decided to make this particular short
film because i've got a headache that
won't go perhaps it's going towards a
migraine
so i'm doing this in case you have a
similar problem some days looking at the
computer too long
just stress you may just get migraines
you might just get headaches you may
never get headaches
so the exercises will be good regardless
so loosen the body
make sure that you feel like a
puppet
on the strings
try to get that that loose that you're
being held up by
the person above you with the controls
but you're really feeling loose
okay
my eyes feel heavy because i've got this
let's say this total headache i'm going
to put my
feet more than hip width apart but
they're
they're pretty straight
okay pretty straight yeah
i'm just gonna now
bring that arms up
and i'm just gonna gaze through this
this circle okay through this circle
now
i'm gonna i often go through things i've
repeated before so i'm just easing
myself into it not in a rush to really
get to the point i'm just
enjoying the doing enjoying the doing
it's as if the puppet master is picked
up this arm picked up this arm
and there they are just hanging in there
on their strings
i'm now going to go push up into my toes
and come up
so i'm on
my toes and the ball of my feet the
balls off my feet
sink down at any time you feel like
you need to have a breather or you need
to just have a rest because it's too
demanding you know
it's not so much the the breather a lot
of people hold their breath when they're
doing
cheek
bother them
breathe through it if your eyes have
chosen a higher gaze than your circle
just bring them up a little but drop the
elbows
try to look through them
as if you've got glazed eyes not staring
eyes
glazed eyes not snowing eyes
i'm now gonna
i've done the demanding part stay there
as long as you can
then slowly go down with your arms
then down with your
slowly your feet so the heels are
touching
my legs are slightly bent
slightly bent
even when i'm up here
they're slightly bent my arms are
slightly bent
they're not kinked but they're slightly
bent
breathe and gaze through the circle
breathing in and out through the nose
or in through the nose out through the
mouth
but i recommend not in and out through
the mouth
this doesn't have the fine control that
you need
you see you can push the breath that way
and it comes out the mouth
but into the nose like gathering it from
all the room and all around me
thank you i'm full
my whole being is from
i give it back to the room or back to
the universe
thank you
this will expand your aura
it will expand your
well-being
it will make you calm
you're connecting with all the things
around you
you can see this tv here you may think
that it's an electronic thing why would
i connect with that but it's part of
it i watch it
the light switch is part of me the door
the handles
so
you know
if they had minds of their own not just
alexa looking at me if they had to bind
their own
they might say thank you for being in
here
and
giving out your
energy it's calm it's powerful
once you've been up
done this
back down your feet should feel firm if
your legs
feel like the muscles are really tight
then you need to ease them out again
you they should have been tense and
strong when you was holding up on the
balls of your feet with the toes
they shouldn't be tense now but
sometimes they are that's just how it is
okay
so now what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to cut one hand over the other you
can choose i use the same
right hand over left ladies left hand
over right or vice versa um i don't know
how important that is but in china i
know they're into acupuncture so it's
very
detailed points but i'm just gonna let
my
own inner spirit
i'm just got my arms i'm thinking now so
i shouldn't be thinking i'm just gonna
do it
so in meditation i would say don't start
questioning whether it's the right way
around or not
if you remember on the other films don't
question
i'll link my fingers i'll touch my
thumbs i'll make it so unhappy
and the reason i done that was i felt as
if my if i relax too much my hands will
fall apart
so either here hands over one or the
other try both see what your preference
is this is the way i teach what is my
preference
thumbs pressed together but not firmly
if there was an old-fashioned cigarette
paper
from a roll-up
you should go to pull it out through
your fingers without tearing thumbs
without tearing it
okay so it's a gentle question
you've closed your eyes slowly
you've sort of adjusted your body you're
moving around you just check
to see where that lovely place is
what you're going to do now is
your structure will hold you up
but your mind needs to come
so each calm
today i'm going to
ask you to with each calming outward
breath
starting at the top of your
starting at the top here your vertebrae
with each outer breath
even if you don't know where they are or
cannot feel them
i'd like to just think about going down
so starting at the top
i'll make a sound but you don't have to
make a sound just breathe very
delicately but just to make a sound for
you
i'm releasing tension by my mind saying
to an extension
as i breathe in i now step down to the
next one
with my mind
i'm doing this with my finger for you
not please don't do that or else you
know how you're gonna get all the way
down
bend these nice soft
sitting posture
now good breath
about the vertebrae that you're you're
at
concentrate on it if it's muddled or
confused don't worry don't let that
bother you just say well it's only my
mind
i'm not in a rush i will take my time
and just
if i can't focus on that particular
vertebra
perhaps i will the next
breathing in
not going down to the next vertical but
yet then when you're fully breath is in
down to the next vertebra
relaxing it the gap in between the gap
in between
the jam in the doughnuts some people say
okay so the challenge is
to go virtually by virtually until you
reach your cockpit
and
don't worry if you think oh i think i've
done that one twice it's your mind
so in meditation we're trying to stop
the mind
keep jumping in
and disturbing our peace
our negative mind you know the monkey
mind
so i hope that helps we've got a blend
of tai chi
with meditation and you need that
because when you stand in
tai chi paul is about to do the form
you touch on
these fingers you touch those fingers
here
gently breathe out
soften the knees
and you
shift the wipe and you move one foot out
and as it goes down
like the exercise
we're ready to start
so
so you do need to understand
meditation
even if it's in a small way
and
she come
will be done together so if you are a
practitioner of
tai chi doesn't matter what
style whose name you follow
the set up should be the same as far as
peace tranquility
good breath
spread it
well-being
these are the signs you know yoga
namaste
tai chi
chico
you know there's different um
there's different thank yous different
endings but they should all be
peaceful
and polite
thank you for your time